[Musique]
bonsoir petits enfants alors que font ce
soir nos deux coquins de nicolas et
pimprenelle nounours tu ne descend pas
les voir je molto prône patron jeu
bolton pourtant tu les aimes bien aux
patrons alors hop 30 en échelle et
dépêche-toi car ils t'attendent tu sais
je ne serai pas long l'open source
assieds toi là nous voulons je suis à ce
procès je te plaise ou non c'est une
petite minute
bon elle est fâchée nicolas non à toi
l'una lune je te vois c'est madame ne
croit que point qu'yves attise 16
enfants
le petits comme les grands
la petite élise yeux qui veut qu'on l'a
freiné son papa jean petit papa qui ne
qui ne qui ne le veut pas l'horoscope
goût pour guérir tes fleurs de toutes
les couleurs
c'est pour toi loeffler tu à l'ours
c'est là aussi tient au mercy dedans que
je suis content vous êtes vraiment ils
ont atteint 6,91 mignan odudu mes petits
allaient bien et colas
[Musique]
punisher gros nounours à demain 12 10
faire mon bien les paupières
on soit papa maman j'ai éteint les
lumières
euros chez le petit
son fond
j'ouvre la fenêtre je sens sans bruit
les encens peut-être
sont endormis
je reprends bonus
le
je connais
aux chômeurs
[Musique]
nicolas mas prônait
e
je
à tort
eh bien je crois que notre nounours est
très content oh oui alors ce qu'ils sont
gentils ces petits et ils m'ont dit que
j'étais mignons ils sont allés sages
vont se coucher
je vis ça suffit nous moi aussi je suis
heureux qu'il soit si sage fait comme
nicolas et pimprenelle des enfants
allaient sagement lit et faites de beaux
rêves
bonne nuit faute de boer
[Musique]